great yeah good to see everyone here
welcome to the
may pie data triangle meetup i'm arthi
um
i'll be the host i currently work as a
data scientist for cisco
um and passionate about data science so
cool let's see
so here we go
yeah so as you know vlassis usually
hosts these meetings
um but now we're on zoom and
flashes is an advertising and marketing
intelligence company that
uses data to enable marketing and
digital success
another one of our sponsors is num focus
and num focus is an organization that
promotes
open practices and research and data and
computing so
thanks to our sponsors here
um i'm sure everyone has seen the code
of conduct but um as a review
pi data is dedicated to providing a
harassment free conference experience
for everyone so
please be kind and professional
and as we like to say don't be mean be
above average
another announcement we've gone by
monthly so
um we meet at the first wednesday of odd
months so our next meetup will be
july 7th so hope to see everyone there
and before we get into announcements uh
just a quick question to you all
how can we serve the content that you
want to need so we're really interested
in hearing from everyone and learning
what sort of data science topics
interest you or if you know
someone who would be interested in
presenting um just to kind of
make this conference the the most useful
and most
um helpful for all of our attendees so
please contact any one of us either
through meetup or through email if you
have
any thoughts on any of these points
cool i guess um from that we can go into
event announcements and jobs
so does anyone have anything to share
interesting events job opportunities
now's the time
uh i have a announcement go for it
okay so um because i've got an excel
spreadsheet
addiction i got involved with alteryx
designer
i'm in the user group leadership we're
having a
our quarterly meeting next wednesday
if anyone is interested i'll post it in
the
uh in the comment section it's
we're going to be talking about process
analytic process automation
and also uh
neo4j charting so
if interested i'll just drop the uh
the link in there no obligation to join
the group
just attend the the online meetup
thank you cool
anyone else
we have a number of uh engineering
and um and a couple data scientist
openings
um at colossus um
we are um uh hiring a lot of remote
as well so i don't know most folks are
local but
i think you know there may be a few that
are out of town but
they um the the the engineering
positions
are um software engineering across a
number of different fronts i would
i would suggest going out to the uh the
last
dot com careers site and and look at the
job descriptions there
awesome
any other events or jobs
cool okay um yeah let's move on to
well actually i um maybe we can talk if
anyone has an idea about uh lightning
talk and this could be
a talk about any sort of data science
topic that interests you
um you can speak for like five to ten
minutes or less
um in any format um please let me know
in the chat
um and we can cover those at the end
but uh with that we can get started so
is
vic on the call i'm
on oh can you hear me yes awesome that's
cool
so um vic has been a software engineer
for 12 years with the focus on big data
his current role he works at google
solving customer ai issues in the
public sector space um so vic do you
want to take it away
sure um yeah so i'm i intend to be
presenting
um about code forecasting so our team
in the last project worked on
forecasting the spread of the disease
and it's pretty contemporary so i
figured it would be an interesting topic
um this is my first time using zoom so i
apologize for my
lack of zoom experience um i'm gonna try
and present the screen
and let me start
there you go
all right um i hope you guys can see the
screen right now
awesome yeah i'm used to using google
internal products and
not zoom so this is a new experience for
me
all right let me try presenting this
all right um so yeah so this is not just
um
my work this is a team of about 30
engineers so i'm not talking for any of
those 30 i'm just talking about my
experiences with this
and again anything i talk about are my
own views about this project
and not google's so yeah
so putting all of that all of those
disclaimers aside
um just want to start with like a very
rough introduction on
how this project started and this was um
like a lot of projects at google uh
bottoms up engineering driven effort and
at this they started right around the
start of the pandemic
and we realized we are talking to a
bunch of folks in the public sector
space
who are interested in understanding
what's happening and what to do
and they were like looking for feedback
and
part of that feedback required having
some kind of systematic process to be
able to focus the future
and forecasting the future is a
notoriously hard problem so i i assume
like
we knew from the start this is not going
to be great but even if we provided them
with black box models
it was not going to be very helpful we
knew that from the start because
policy decisions can't be made from a
black box model so one of the goals of
our
model early on was to make it
interpretable and understandable
so we were a claudia team and we had
we understood that what was happening
had significant
significant impacts downstream so we
figured
let's try to solve this let's build a
minimum viable prototype
see if we can even build something that
an epidemiologist will understand
not a computer scientist
so what we did we essentially as part of
this we've
generated a bunch of forecasts these are
publicly available
they predict the spread of
hospitalizations ico admissions
confirmed cases
it is trained using public data only
there is no
google specific secret source involved
the models are also
described on um our archive papers which
are publicly available
we have an europe's uh paper as well and
the nature
publication and in the works
so yeah so essentially we want to
like i said the goal was to ensure that
this model was not just a black box ml
model
but something that we could provide to
an epidemiologist
and they would be able to peek into the
model to understand if it made
sense so um
again uh continuing with the theme of
what we did
we provided a white paper we have these
public data sets we also publish
the entire data set um as part of
bigquery so you can actually download
the csv file
our forecasts are part of the national
response portal this is um
something that the federal government
set up together to
estimate the spread of the disease and
it's it's basically a collection of a
bunch of models
that come together to predict where
things are going and
there is some evidence to indicate that
this combined model is actually
much better than any of these individual
models
and very importantly we also published
evidence on fairness analysis we know
this
disease has disproportionately affected
people of color
and therefore it was very important for
us to ensure that um
the error rates that we have that we
have for our model
are not favoring uh favoring communities
of
uh favoring on like uh
disadvantaging communities of color in
anywhere
so part of this work was also in
publishing this fairness analysis to
indicate to
to prove that this portal was truly fair
and like i said the biggest challenges
in this space was
integrating human expertise like this is
the heart
this is the hard part of air you you can
solve a black you can create a black box
model that will probably outperform
a bunch of models but there is very
little information to get
out to make it interpretable
understandable and
get a sense semblance of confidence on
the system
so uh this was the biggest challenge
to start out with the second challenge
was the environment was changing
continuously and they were like
the changing environment is very
relevant because
environments change not just because of
interventions
like policy decisions people putting in
um
people putting in restrictions like
mobility restrictions where
they have a lock lock and lock down in
place order curfews or like
business specific like all restaurants
should need to be closed or daycares
need to be closed
and these were changing and they were
not only just changing um
by like the country they were changing
by state by county
so even when there were policies at the
top level
the level at which they were enforced
were very different so this made this
disease very difficult because there is
no
uniform data set that informs
is the policy in place has it been
enforced
so we had to imply a lot of this
information
uh and then there were many data sets
because of this um
epidemic there were so many data science
published the hard one of the big
challenges was
figuring out which data sets to use and
uh
and as you'll see later on one of the
analysis that one of our
problems was we could get in a lot of
data sets
and essentially build a very complex
model and overfit
so we had to do like fancy
regularization techniques to ensure that
we were not creating uh an
overly over parameterized model
and there was one thing unique about
this data set
which is about the disease itself which
is the undocumented cases
so most disease when you try to model
them you have a good sense like ebola or
any of these diseases you have a good
sense of the number of people that are
potentially susceptible to the disease
how many are exposed how many are
infected at a given point in time
because
any anybody who usually gets exposed
gets uh or infected
it gets hospitalized but in the case of
the covet virus
it was asymptomatic which made it really
difficult to have a sense of
what are the true number of people who
are affected and not having good data as
inputs can make a lot of models like
bad with their outputs garbage and
garbage out
so yeah so data sources are noisy again
due to collection issues
noisy is a very what should i say
a generous term they were noisy to the
point where
uh they were restating ground throats
every day so what happens
is the new york times or ghu were the
most famous data sets
when they published their results they
were published
they would publish data for from this
point to the past
right up to the 22nd of january
and very often if you compare the data
sets yesterday's ground truth for all of
these days to today's ground truth for
all of these days
except that one day that you got today
the new additional day
you would see there are huge differences
and this was a problem because
the authorities were restating ground
truth all the time they were going back
and saying oh
this debt that was attributed to covet
is not actually a covert death or this
death
that was not attributed is now coveted
so the ground truth not only
was shifting it was shifting not for
every single day in the future like
going forward
but every single day in the past this
was a big challenge
and um if anybody's interested i'm happy
to talk about how we had to tackle this
problem
but this resulted in very fundamental
philosophical questions like
uh should we build a model that looks
good 14 days from now 28 days from now
five years from now because there are
they are all different problems
so let me talk about traditional
epidemiology to get
to provide some motivation about how
epidemiologists
think about the spread of a disease
so today today the gold standard is
something called the
s-e-i-r model s stands for susceptible
e stands for exposed i is for infectious
and r
is for removed or recovered so
people use different terms depending
upon whom you're talking to but usually
it is recovered for the most part
so these models are essentially you can
think of them as compartments
so you can think of when the coed
pandemic started
the entire population say of the u.s was
in a susceptible bucket some some some
portion of them were exposed
and some people were infectious and some
people had recovered from the
um from the disease and you can think of
these
people transitioning from these boxes at
any given point in time
so you go from susceptible to exposed to
infectious to remote or recovered so
what the sci model tries to do is
provide these
given this seir model you can specify
these different rates
and this was a nice visualization
provided by the new york times
where you could actually go in and take
a look and specify the populations you
can see the size of the population as
input
the basic reproductive reproduction
number which basically controls
how many from susceptible go to exposed
and all of these parameters are
essentially controlling
the rate at which things go from one
compartment to the next
so you can see over here susceptible is
basically
um rt which is at time zero
uh at any given point in time with the
entire population exposed is basically
the set of people who are in
uh as a set of transitions of people
getting out of exposed
the exposed compartment minus the ones
coming in that's a set of people in the
recovered compartment and
if you look at the differential equation
for infected it's the same thing
it's the number of people coming in
minus the number of people coming out of
the compartment
so this is a very simple model but it
has
worked remarkably remarkably well and
some problems with this model is these
um i'll touch upon this later as well is
that
these parameters these are zero these
transmission rates
are effectively static so you can say at
this point in time this is how we
believe the disease is going to progress
the problem is this only is a point in
time
accurate this is not accurate going
forward for instance you can
predict one peak and one
one pump like one peak just one single
peak using
the standard sci model but as we know
the disease progresses spreads
slows down and spreads again and that is
not very easy to capture
so you what you really want to do is be
able to capture these
these variables dynamically in terms of
time
i.e these parameters these transmission
rates that we have for these
compartments
need to be dynamic and not static
and that's what that's what was our big
insight essentially we
we took the compartmental model and
asked the question can we learn these
transmission rates
given the data and we built our own
version of the compartmental model
that learned these transmission rates
dynamically over time
and um and predicted where things are
going to be so if you
if you take a look at our compartmental
model you can see it has a standard
buckets of susceptible exposed infected
and recovered but you'll also notice we
have something called
documented infected and undocumented in
factor because it's a special for covet
because the number of undocumented
infected cases are significantly larger
than the number of documented infected
cases
so we built this fancy model and we
added a bunch of new compartments
and this is primarily because we were
trying to inform
inform bits bits and pieces about
hospital hospitalization supply chain
issues
where supplies are needed where we
believe there's going to be a next hike
and we are informing
policy for various state governments so
this is the reason
we had this very specialized compartment
on ventilators ico and hospitalized and
death as well
so um often we did not have all of the
data
and which in which case when we didn't
have the data we used to basically just
drop those compartments off and just use
a simpler compartment just for depth
so you can see all of these rates over
here they're very similar to the
previous
differential equations equation model
that you saw
and essentially these are parameters
that provide
the pro information with the rate of
transmission from one compartment to the
next
and all of these variables are then uh
calculated based on covariance like
mobility the changes in mobility uh
senses
and even the progression of the disease
itself
so i can provide a lot more information
about these
compartments if there is any interest
but this is
this um this diagram effectively
represents
our model and everything else from here
is just going to be explaining about the
different aspects of how
these things look like how we went about
doing these things so if anybody has any
questions this would be a good time to
pause and take any questions
hey vic so there's a couple questions in
the chat
or um yeah i'm not being paying
attention to the chat uh
let me open that up quickly
sure i could also share oh no
i i'll i'll open up the chat i think
that will be easier
i am
i have not done this before so i'm
trying to figure out where
[Music]
you know what i'm going to take your
offer okay have you
screen share and answer those questions
let me stop sharing
sure yeah um so a question from
mark uh did the i guess these are more
general i don't know if they're
totally related to the
compartmentalization but um the first
question
did the changes in the cdc reporting
hamper your work
at all um ta had significant
consequences
i think um initially we did not
recognize that
the amount of change that was happening
to the crown truth and it was a while
later that we realized oh my god the
ground truth under us is shifting quite
a bit
and that was a wake-up call for us
because we realized
uh when you're doing model comparisons
you'll compare this week's model using
you'll build a model using this
this week's data provide evaluation
matrix
next week you'll repeat the same process
but using the latest ground through
and because you're using the latest
ground truth and the ground truth used
for
both these models are completely
different they're actually not
comparable
so we ended up making some bad choices
and our modeling
decisions because of this but once we
caught up
to this that the um the quality of once
they called once we realized that this
is happening
and we can't control for it we basically
decided to basic
uh to check mark our ground through that
any given point in time so if you have a
new model
and if you're comparing two models we
ensure that the inputs the ground
through the inputs for them are exactly
using the same as of the day that the
previous model was
um evaluated so that was one big problem
for us it slowed us down
quite a bit and this was right before we
were going to publish
so it was a good catch it was before we
published and before it was embarrassing
that google published results that were
not like that models were that were not
like
truly essentially what a result of we
did that was
our models in production would not be
a validation um evaluation
would not be comparable to what would
happen in production
so it was it was nice recorded and fixed
that earlier on
great um another question from matthew
uh what regularization techniques did
you use
so we had to use um
so i i don't think i can fully answer
this question
but um we did uh
we had a study station on the team who
did this and i can provide some slides
about
uh information about which limited we
had to select
we had to be very judicious in our
choice of the parameters we use for the
model because like i said we could use a
ton of
data sets and then overfit on these
parameters and we had to be
a judicious in the selection and then
even after that
during a model evaluation itself we had
significant we uh at the start of the
project we used a significant amount of
l1 and l2 loss
i i don't know what else it has changed
since then so i have not looked at the
model since then so i don't know the
current one is
so the next question is from conrad who
says
have we decided what the ground truth um
for what a covid death is
many of the deaths attributed to coveter
from underlying conditions
so this is a lack so so we trust the
information provided by jhu
and um the ny times we
we don't know their process of
determining whether the death was caused
by
covert or underlying conditions so
both the ghu and new york times include
this information
and i believe they line up very well
so i don't know what mechanism it is but
it seems to be
that even though they are independent
agencies providing this ground truth
there is
some standard i'm not aware of what it
is
i guess this is a related question from
mike but how
you tackled the problem of inaccuracy
with data in your model
um uh
this was um
so we worked out on this by basically
building a more robust model
and and robust in the sense that is
something that is understandable by
experts so
given our model we could actually take
out the parameters the learned
parameters and hand it to an expert and
which we did with
professors at harvard and they would
look at this model and say
these parameters make sense or they do
not make service
so even though our models were learned
using data the output
was actually an epidemiological model
that people could work with
and they didn't care about really how
this model was generated
the accuracy of the model was more
important and building this
epidemiological model that people today
have encouraged
without with just like absolutely no
expertise
in a sense you don't know what the
parameter value should be for these
models so they
they fit these parameters based on what
they are observing
and part of the problem with the covert
virus was
there was very little confidence on the
quality of the data
and therefore building a model that also
accounted for this was
i think um the game changer essentially
that was the biggest
the novel contribution of our work being
able to take
ml and apply it to an epidural
epidemiological model
and then use that epidemiological model
for forecasting
hope that helps yeah um
a question from see
david um are the seir variables
continuous or discrete
so by variables i assume you mean the
transmission
um the the
rate variables essentially those are
continuous
um mark asks can you speak about covid19
deaths
and excess deaths
um is this i'm not sure what this
is maybe maybe mark could elaborate a
bit more on the question
um somebody had done a study
about excess death some deaths that
were not directly attributable to covet
19
and they included several different
categories of
related hearts and because because the
ace
uh the the ace protein was used or the
ace receptor was used
um by the uh sars cove two
um virus
they they included okay we're going to
include deaths from
um uh pulmonary just pulmonary disorders
and renal disorders and
and look for excess deaths and
uh as of november
2020 there were 300 000
um excess deaths or
299 000 uh excess deaths
but i didn't know if you if you could
speak to
the excess death versus uh confirmed
no that's a great question i don't know
um i was not aware of the excess that's
being
provided as a statistic or um would you
know what a good data source for this
information is uh
well okay well while you're talking i'll
see if i can find
it i'll post it in the chat yeah so so
fundamentally the problem was
because these deaths were being reported
on a daily basis and there was not good
quality
that is what is resulting in these three
statements going back into the past
all the time and that was fundamentally
that is the fundamental problem and that
was something that we caught early
and we were also able to inform the
general academy community because we
were not the only ones making this
mistake
turns out um there were a bunch of
places that were providing these
aggregate information and we
we were part of those multiple
consortiums and we were able to publish
and
expose this problem to a lot of other
teams
but i don't think there is a good way
for us to
identify this without going down to like
the personal
like down to the data and hospitals that
were actually reporting this information
and i think yeah i i can't add more than
that
um so uh i just posted something from
jama
and it shows they're it shows their
methodologies
this is interesting thank you but but
but i was i've been looking for
something that covered
after november or after october what
whatever it was and i really haven't
seen an update
um to that study
i see yeah i'm this is this is new for
me as well so i think i'm going to have
to spend some time looking at this
myself
useful feedback for us to think through
okay i i just
i didn't want to side track your
presentation but but i thought it
you know if you'd also looked at that it
it may have been insightful
yeah especially um yeah i i definitely
agree this is something useful
to think about and i can provide some
insights going down
as we go forward about how we perform
provide different kinds of supervision
to the model as well
so this is one example of supervision we
could provide but
i don't know how good the data is we
need to look at the data so
i'll use another example as part of this
so
let me go back to the presentation
share screen
all right so here we were describing
um the scir model and like i mentioned
um
we did a bunch of additional things like
and
um so in this case what we're
highlighting is we were thinking about
reinfections well before
we had multiple variants so you can see
we had a rate variable that went from
recovered back to susceptible this means
you could
potentially this also helped with the
vaccination example where we knew
we were going to have vaccines with some
efficacy percentage like
when we are doing some water scenarios
you're thinking about 70
would be awesome and we ended up getting
vaccines with 90. that was
that was great but this would provide
this kind of information where
you would only have 70 percent um
actually recovered so
you would have roughly 30 probability of
still transitioning to
susceptible so we could also control
these variables
without um providing any addition we
could learn these variables
how well the vaccination was progressing
in a population and stuff like that
using
by studying these different variables
yeah and this talks about the process of
how we basically used time varying
functions to basically learn these
various
transition functions
i'm going to skip on the slide yeah and
like i said uh
one of the biggest learnings from this
exercise was a
we built all of this infrastructure on
google on
gcp which is google's external cloud
infrastructure and not internal to
google
and the intent for that was because this
was a academic for the most part
and b we also want to test out
how well external data sources work and
it was a
great learning experience but we also
learned the hardware
maintaining data quality is heard and
keeping
tabs and checks on data quality was one
of the harder problems that we had
because
you could have changes day to day where
suddenly you would have
uh no no reports and then they would
just report zeros
and you would just be like the model
would be confused because it's like
it's been predicting uh cumulative debt
so far up to like
some number n and suddenly the next day
drops to zero and
cumulative curves don't go down right
they always go up
so that was like like fixing these kinds
identifying these data qualities and
fixing them was hard
historical data quality was a big
problem there would be dips even in
these cumulative curves
which made no sense so we had to put
like sanity checks in place
model catching issues with modern
quality
like when you're dealing with time
series forecasting a one-off
issue can be very serious because you
can then leak
labels into your forecast that's never a
good idea
and then infrastructure because we built
you're probably one of the biggest users
of
of ml gcp on google at the time at which
we went public
that's because we are doing so much
hyper parameter optimization
we basically um we basically almost
caused an outage in one of the regions
which was
fun yeah and
you can look at the quality of our
predictions these are like a few cherry
picked examples
we on average we do much better than
most models
especially models where especially for
states of
large populations uh you can see over
here the
the the light the the dotted lines
are our predictions and the ones with
the crosses are the actual ground truth
and you can see the these two curves the
green curves are usually close to each
other and
for the most part and this is the state
level model
we also had a county level model so
um here
another example so so one thing that was
also special about our model was
most models predict an independent curve
for
deaths an independent curve for ground
truths for like confirmed cases
we were able to predict using one model
all of these parameters
so it was a single model generating all
parameters versus
other black box models they you
generally had independent
models predicting that's another model
predicting ground truth
which made it even more difficult sorry
difficult to reason with
um yes and then we also had county level
models so
an example of where we use supervision
was so so our county
so we i believe were one of very few
models that provided county level
forecasts and this was very important
especially at the county level
and state level city level for making
decisions the city of new york actually
was one of our
uh i cannot talk about this i'm sorry um
i am going to skip over this but
essentially um
the predictions at the county level were
very high quality
and the reason for that was we were able
to build models at the state level
and these state level models were really
good they worked they're comparable to
some of the best models out there
and at any given point in time the best
model we were in the top five
models at any given point in time but a
county level models are almost always
usually the best and that's because
we provided supervision to the county
level models
such that like the sum of all counties
should not like
significantly exceed the state level
models prediction so
we would basically train a state level
model and then use that state level
model to supervise the county level
model
which was which helped us like improve
our country level performance
significantly
there are still some issues you as you
will realize
county level models are not are going to
be very noisy as you can see in these
examples over here
but usually we were on we were the best
county model out there at any given
point in time
all right so yeah and like i said we
were able to provide these transition
parameters at any given
point in time with experts and they were
able to
provide us feedback and help a improve
the quality of our model
but b also inform policy decisions
downstream
um the second bit was understanding of
like because we had an interpretation
interpretable model you could actually
take a look down into the details about
how each of these input covariates were
affecting
uh the spread of the disease so in this
case we plotted different
uh different graphs so you can see like
on the 24th of may
uh 24th of may 2020 it was
the the red line indicates shelter in
place so shelter in place policies
gained importance
but they dropped in importance over time
and you can do this for all of these
various metrics so uh here's another
example where you can see
the importance for shelter and page
dropping and the importance for
confirmed and
the ground through the improvement and
when ground truth becomes important
that's an indication that
the model is biasing information like
trend level information or like people
call these momentum
information more highly compared to
other covariates like mobility
and that's also because at different
points in time people are introducing
these mass mandates
so suddenly when earlier in the spread
of the disease mobility was really
important
as time went mobility became less
important and this was evident in our
models
and this was you could see as mass
mandates came in
mobility took less of an importance and
these
other interventions like closures for
businesses
different kinds of interventions that we
had data for start taking precedence and
yeah so that was very useful not just
for us
but also policy makers to see their
decisions actually taking effect
and finally like this is a small slide
on fairness analysis
and you can see that on average our mean
absolute error
was usually less than one percent um
there are a lot of conforming factors
over here i should add with the caviar
which is
um our populations are not very well
mixed
that means generally what we've observed
was um
[Music]
the black population tends to be in
larger cities
and we do well in larger cities versus
uh rural areas
so a lot of these biases are like
confounded with a lot of other
a lot of other confounding factors but
on average we were able to
keep our we were able to observe very
similar
errors across all demographics
and i'm happy to talk about the computer
infrastructure but uh
let's just say we were doing a lot at
any given point
there were points in time when we were
using over 100 000 vms
to run hyper parameter tuning um we
were so big at one point in time that
they
basically had to um set up machines
at a data center to help keep keep our
project going
so this was a fun project i'm happy to
talk about stories over there
for the most part we use bigquery and
kubeflow if
people are not i'm happy to provide like
details on both of these if there is
interest i'll take them
towards the end with questions and
we have a bunch of learnings over here
um
if we liked solving a this was very
satisfying because we solved an
important problem
and we helped inform policy that was a
big win for us
all also while getting a good rep for
google
for this whole process um we were super
users for google
and learning about like large and it's
good to be able to build
these large systems without having
having to actually
know the details of how it is actually
done so that was like super nice this is
the first time i actually built
something outside of google
and we were able to build a phenomenally
complex system
without knowing the details of how
things worked which was
really nice um
again then the last thing was a focus on
launching responsibly that was a great
learning experience because
there were points in time where we
really wanted to launch and
we like like we identified the issues
with the ground truth
and this was um this helped us also
cement a solid rep in the academic space
because
we were able to push for uh ideas most
people were not thinking of
well ahead of the crowd and that helped
improve not just our forecasting
capabilities but for the entire
community and um all
all of the cdc as well
and like i said fairness was on top of
mind this is something we baked into our
models early on to avoid
um even though it is very tempting to
include
to include more demographic information
knowing that demographics helps
better predict um health with better
prediction it was
really hard to balance those two and we
kept this in mind throughout and that
was one of the
things that helped eventually land a
model that we know
for a fact was fair
and then finally we had to answer like
hard philosophical questions like
should we publish this now or publish it
until we have more confidence
in the quality of models because there's
always this factor that
by pushing out these forecasts early
you'll help save
lives help make better policy decisions
versus
yeah that was a that was i think one of
the hard problems
that as an engineer you want to build a
perfect system while at the same time
you have
a pandemic ongoing and you want to
launch
quickly so we have we've spent a bunch
of nights
going through getting things up and
running knowing the
the cost of delay
so yeah that's that's pretty much it
from me and i think i'm also on time
so i'm going to stop and
maybe take a few minutes with any
questions
awesome thank you so much vic
so vic thank you very much i really
enjoyed your presentation
um i was thinking about all the
predictions you were making and working
with other folks did you
pay much attention to thinking about
causality in the modeling you were doing
because some of the fundamental
questions are
you know your projections are causal in
nature and or
the actions are causal nature i was
curious what you thought about that
yeah so that is where the having a
standard epidemiological
model and hand came very handy
because even though we can't predict
causality and causality
is a is a brutally hard problem because
we had a
epidemiological model we don't need to
explain causality as long as we could
show these are the learned parameters
and this is just replacing humans who
would have been plugging in those
parameters to figure out
what to do next this was just a machine
figuring out those parameters
learning those parameters and providing
them so because
we had this existing framework that we
could plug into
we didn't have to answer this question
of causality
so essentially the model captured the
expertise for the humans and they could
infer causality out of it
so no so to answer a question no we did
not
try to answer causality and we know it's
a it's a very hard problem
cool any other questions uh i think
matthew you had a few um
in the chat um i'll i'll let you speak
for those
oh okay um yeah first of all just uh
more details about the
the model uh if you could um
i mean it seems like you just had a
handful or a few dozen parameters
um and it looked like it's a
differentiable model so i guess you're
doing a gradient descent there
to learn those all right okay so then i
asked why did you need six trillion
petawatts of compute for a model with a
few dozen parameters
i got a hard time getting my head around
that so so the complexity was not in
the parameters themselves each of these
parameters were being learned
and each of these parameters were being
learned simultaneously in the same graph
that was the complexity essentially
being able to
train each for each time step you would
basically train all of these independent
variables roll the graph one step
forward repeat the same process and you
repeat this time step for each
for each time step that would be just
one
run and you would do this maybe uh uh
500 times with different type of
parameters so that would give you one
trained model
okay and when you're doing modeling when
you're doing like
like five or six people are trying out
different ideas let's use this covariate
we have a team of almost 30 engineers so
all of these 30 engineers
say trying out just one idea means 30 of
these
runs 30 of these 500
um parameter runs that's 1500 runs each
of these
15 like of these 1500 runs you can
imagine each run is taking about
100 machines you can easily see how you
can see how much
how quickly you can cross that barrier
for a hundred thousand machines
yeah so it does does sound like just an
overfitting nightmare um
and i guess you had to bend over
backwards to make sure
that wasn't happening i mean there's
huge potential for
yes so that is where the regularization
and the judicious use of
which which data do we use to calc for
which um which variables which
transmission
variables was the key yeah i assume you
guys did that did that right and then i
guess the other question i had was um
you showed uh feature slide 19 was a
feature importance uh you showed the
relative
feature importance but you would have
had to have done some kind of
normalization
of the yes so i'm wondering how you did
that
so all of the weights that we um all the
weights in our model were eventually
normalized
as inputs between zero minus one and
plus one
and then we knew because everything is
normalized in the same range
we knew which parameters was equal and
then we know which parameters weighted
higher
which you tell us and so how did you how
did you
put them into that zero to negative one
of one range
oh this is just standard uh
normalization techniques that we used
uh that wasn't did you z-score them is
that what you're saying i mean you just
oh i mean z-scoring you can z-score
input data
that's standard normalization but but
normalizing parameters there's i'm not
aware of
standard normalization to give you a
concrete example um you can think of a
population as
uh so everything is normalized a by
population so
you if you have like area as an example
so you're
calculating density matrix so so
you would basically normalize that a by
population first and then
uh normalize this i do not know the
answer
normalization differed depending upon
the kind of parameter you're normalizing
for
right so i mean just just uh here's the
point one of your covariates was a
presence of um
stay-at-home mandate right yeah so
that's like that's like a binary value
parameter
and then you're comparing that on the
same graph with something like
population density
right which is a scalar continuous
variable right and and so you know you
you're now you can do it can be done but
it's non-trivial
to to make a valid comparison between
those i'm yeah just wondering
yes um uh i was not the one who did that
comparison i can look into that and
provide more details
but i can uh yeah okay
you did it somehow okay thank you
anyone else uh hi vic nice presentation
i have a quick question and i might have
missed this uh
you mentioned about fairness um i wanted
to ask
[Music]
did you explicitly did do anything to
to enforce the fairness other than let's
say not use demographic information
or things like that um
no so that's actually one of the
questions you asked us part of our
fairness analysis
we um we initially were planning to use
like demographic
demographic information uh the model
showed better results but we ended up
not using it eventually
um but again like i said this was a at a
point in time i don't know how that
decision would have changed like how
that would affected the model later on
but yeah that was one of the things we
actively did not include
um there were other um questions about
ferris is hard because of the number of
confounders so even though we know for a
fact that
uh the model is on average less than one
percent mae
it is not it is non-trivial to take out
the effects purely based on
race so we understand the limitations
and
this is something that we even discussed
in the paper
okay i see thanks
all right cool uh i think there's a
question in the chat uh where can we
read the conclusions drawn from your
study if you have
a url i can post the article
in your paper
sweet so i'll post those chat um
and you should be able to access them
cool yeah if um yeah thanks so much for
your time if
nothing else we can move on to um our
next talk
let me share my screen here
can everyone see my screen
yeah i can see it okay cool um our next
speaker is nizark
nissar has a phd in computer science
from duke university
and since then he has been an ml
engineer at linkedin
um and us and he's currently working as
a senior software engineer
at nmworld innovations
so whenever you're ready okay
um thanks let me share my screen
okay can everyone see my screen yep
okay awesome um thanks
uh for inviting me to this uh forum
um um i'm going to talk about
uh how do we protect secrets in the data
using adversarial nets and this is um
a joint work that i did when i was a
duke doing my phd
uh with ashwin landon and jerry
um so it's a collaborative effort
um and feel free to stop and ask
questions if you have any
um because i can't see the chats right
now
um okay so so this is a very simplified
view
of what an ml lifecycle looks like uh
i'm
sure a lot of you are aware of it we
have
a training data set we apply some ml
algorithms and we get a
model out of it and then you have a
second step where you deploy this model
and use it to run
inference on new data points so
there are a bunch of privacy problems
that occur across these
phases um i'll stick to the
phase where we deploy the model and when
we run the inference on the new data
points
how do we protect sensitive information
in the new data points
there is a host of research on how do we
protect the information in the training
data itself
and how do we make sure that the model
itself does not leak
information about the training data and
that's a separate topic
um okay so
to build um some groundwork and
motivation towards
why this is important um
user data is extremely important to
provide any service
um be it an autonomous driving
text translation app or security apps so
like
you you need user data at every moment
to do something about it so like in
autonomous driving case you capture the
information continuously from your
surrounding you
do detections like detecting the lanes
detecting the pedestrians and so on
and all of these data is collected
analyzed
and it produces some
useful output that the application
relies on
and nowadays the
one model of the apps is that you
collect information
from user and their surroundings
and then ship that data onto the cloud
where
you have giant machine learning models
crunching
that information and spitting some
output
and that output is then used to take
some actions or
give some information to the user back
the problem with this is that um
you might uh lose some privacy and you
might
leak some information that you don't
want to so
so let's take a very concrete example of
a driver safety app
imagine you have a dashboard cam that's
continuously monitoring driver
and the idea is that you want to analyze
the frames
and figure out whether the driver is
paying attention
or not so in order to do that one way to
do is you
capture the frames you run some ml model
to detect activities like whether the
person is texting
whether the person is looking down and
so on um
so i call these sort of information as
app and app essential information
um that's necessary for app to function
um but at the same time you are also
revealing sensitive information
because the same image can be used to
analyze
information like an identity of a person
or race
or gender so i call these information as
private information now
most of the apps do collect user
information at a large scale
and then they analyze them to to give
useful information but at the same time
you
can have a risk of either maliciously
or accidentally leaking sensitive
information in the data that's being
corrected
so um i mean we will
go back to this example often as we go
along the presentation
and that will be used as an anchor point
to understand
how what are the problems and how do we
solve it
so a simple solution is why don't we
keep the user data on the device
like um we instead bring back the model
on the device instead of cloud
do not send any data on the cloud do all
the processing on the
on the device itself and that is indeed
being done
in many cases like tensorflow lite is an
example where
the push is to do on on-device
computation
and not only it has benefits in terms of
privacy but it also has benefits in
terms of
uh response time because you don't have
to send everything to the cloud and you
can just
do the competition on the fly however in
in in practice that's limited because
um the devices are not that great in
terms of resources you have a capacity
so you have a limitation on the capacity
at which you can do the computation
and you can also have problems like you
can have proprietary models that
you don't want to ship it to the device
and
the models are continuously changing uh
and it's hard
so uh and the last problem is you
eventually need to trust the app because
from user's perspective the apps are
black box and
you don't know what the app is doing
internally so
even if you could have a malicious app
that
claims to be doing on-device processing
but can still send data out there on the
cloud
so what we propose is is we want to
obfuscate the data
before it reaches the app so that
we don't need to trust the app and uh we
don't need to bring the model
on the device and the idea is it should
work seamlessly
um having said that there are and again
um the the work we did applies to
data that's beyond images like it
applies to sensor data as well but
throughout the presentation i'll stick
to images because it's easier to explain
so in in case of image in particular
you could apply some naive obfuscation
techniques like you can
blur the image you can do pixelation
where you hide the sensitive information
and the problem is the problems with
these approaches
are that you have to balance between
privacy and utility so
uh if you blur too much you lose the
utility because
those images will be useless and if you
blur too little
then you have a risk of revealing
information
in fact the there are a lot of work that
shows that
even if you blur to some extent you can
still
identify information uh using
state-of-the-art neural network models
um mainly because it doesn't hide all
the information
and the other reason is there is also a
context
so you can hide a face but then the
surroundings like the people who
you are with the location and all those
information can be used to
actually pinpoint you so those are the
main
challenges of these naive obfuscation
mechanisms
so we we basically
so this is a concrete problem statement
right you
we want to construct an obfuscation
mechanism
that hides private information in the
user data
with a minimal impact on the app's
utility
so the idea again going back to the
driver safety app is that
we want to put the office schedule in
between the
sensor and the app so that once you
obfuscate the data
the app can still function on the off
screen data meaning
it can still identify the activities
such as texting
um whether the hands are on the wheel
and so on
but at the same time it should not be
able to identify
sensitive information such as race or
gender or direct identity
so this is what we refer to as utility
aware of the station
um so the rest of the talk is
outlined as follows we'll first
describe how do we come up with such an
obfuscation mechanism
then i'll talk about olympus which is
the framework
that uses these principles to build an
obfuscation mechanism
uh and then finally i'll describe a
bunch of evaluation results that we
did to evaluate how good the olympus
works in real life
any questions before i move on
okay so let's see
um
so here is the idea behind the whole
work
the we we are proposing to use neural
networks to learn as well as verify the
obfuscation
uh neural networks are universal
approximate so
meaning they can be used to approximate
a lot of different functions
um with certain constraints and the the
idea here is that why can't we use
neural network to also learn the
obfuscation mechanism
that satisfies our criteria now once we
learn such a mechanism
we also want to verify whether that
particular mechanism
is valid or not so we also use neural
network to verify
that information and it might
uh look uh odd but
that works basically you you have these
two
networks that compete each with each
other
and in doing so they actually come up
with
the best possible obfuscation mechanism
so
to understand this uh how do we do this
let's look at the concept of generative
adversarial networks or
popularly known as gan and um i
apologize if you already know about it
but
let me give you a very brief idea of
what
is and how it works so the goal here is
you
want to learn a particular distribution
that the data is following and the
popular use cases you want to
be able to generate realistic images so
the
the way is you have a generator which is
a neural network
you feed in a random noise to the
generator and then
the generator's goal is to output the
data point
and in case of images it tries to output
the image that looks realistic now how
do we verify this
well you add another network which is
called a discriminator that takes in
this
generated data we call it also fake data
in a real data point and it tries to
identify whether the given data point is
real or fake so it some sense it's
it's it's a binary classification
problem um
now in doing so it
helps the generator to learn
to produce realistic data basically you
feed that loss
back to the discriminator and generator
and the idea is that
let's call this loss as the in some
sense
typically it's a cross entropy loss but
at a very high level
it's trying to capture how well
the discriminator is able to distinguish
between real and fake data point
so the goal of the discriminator is to
minimize that loss meaning
it's it should improve the accuracy of
distinguishing between real
and generated data and the goal of the
generators
is opposite meaning it tries to maximize
that loss
so in other words it tries to fool the
discriminator
so eventually it's like a game
they both uh go iteratively
we train them iteratively and eventually
the generator will be able to
generate the data point that is
indistinguishable from the real data
so at some point the discriminators will
reach to a stage where it cannot
identify what's real and what's
generated
and this is popularly known as minimax
optimization problem
and um we can
have iterative methods to
reach equilibrium in some cases of
course it requires a lot of training
data
and computations but
it has been shown that this is possible
so how do we use this idea well we
we thought that in our case
instead of generating a real data point
we would like to remove
sensitive information from the data so
what we do is instead of
having a generator generate a real data
point we call it an office creator
and instead of giving a random input
we are giving the original input like
original data point
and asking it to remove private
information from the data
well how do we first
train such thing and really make it
remove their private information
and the second how do we ensure that it
is indeed removing private information
so to do that just like in gan you use
discriminator
to verify that the generated data is
real we also use
another discriminator if you call it we
call it attacker
which tries to find private information
in the data
and the goal of the attacker is to be
able to
break the obfuscation and we capture it
through
the attacker's accuracy or privacy loss
and then this loss is given back to the
office letter
so that the office creator can learn its
mistakes and then
figure out what went wrong and in the
next iteration
fix it so in the same way
we do in gan this is slightly different
use
framework but the the underlying
principle is same where
the office getter tries to hide private
information
and the attacker tries to infer the
private information
and then whatever loss you get from the
attacker you feed it back to the office
later
so that the obfuscator will um
improve so the goal of the obfuscator is
to minimize privacy loss
but the goal of the attacker is to
maximize privacy loss and we come up
with the same kind of minimax
optimization problem
that we can solve iteratively so far
it's it's it's fine uh the problem is
this is trivially
solvable you can just output a blank
image
or like a constant data point and then
you don't have any private information
in this
but that's clearly useless because we
we we want a utility out of the data as
well
so how do we do this well the first
attempt we tried is
to say that why don't we make sure that
the input
of the obfuscator and the output looks
similar
so basically we force them to be as
close as possible
and the the idea behind this is that
we want the obfuscator to remove the
private information
without changing the data too much so
so in in in practice
what we hoped was to okay if you see
something sensitive
remove it but then keep everything else
because that's right
that might be required for the
downstream applications
the benefit of this approach was you are
not app dependent
you can basically make sure that it
works with
many different applications however
in practice when we actually apply this
technique and when we train it
we it turned out that the it was very
hard to train such an
obfuscator mainly because
the private information and the public
informations
can be very tightly coupled uh for
example again going back to the driver
safety app
you can imagine that the facial
expression that
or facial features can be used to
identify whether the person is looking
straight
or looking down on the other hand
this can also be used to identify a race
or gender
so changing those things um is
necessary for preserving the privacy
but it's bad for preserving the utility
so
that was the problem and in in data
points like images you have these
structure and enforcing that the input
and output looks
same uh also enforces that you have to
keep that structure and
because of that it was very hard to
break this correlation
which was necessary to hide private
information
but really keep the useful information
so then we thought that okay let's put a
constraint
and say that we are going to build an
obfuscation mechanism for a particular
app
or the model within the app that uses
the data
and in doing so we were able to use the
app
or its model to train our office data
so now we added app into the picture and
when i say app i really mean the model
that's used by the app um so that
we feed the obfuscated data to the apps
model
and then whatever error we get from the
model
we call it utility loss and then give
that loss back to the office creator
so now the office cutter has both
privacy loss and utility loss
and the goal is now to minimize both of
these losses
so by minimizing privacy loss you are
trying to hide private information and
by minimizing it
loss you are trying to keep app
essential information
um so this is the summary of the
approach
well you have three components you have
an obfuscator
we have an attacker and we have an app
and
the goal is that we the office creator
should learn
to remove the private information but
keep the app essentially
app essential information and that's
captured through this
optimization function um
we do linear combination of privacy loss
and
utility loss with the parameter k so
that you can balance privacy and utility
um and then the attacker is trained to
maximize the privacy loss
so that it can then lead the obfuscator
to
actually learn the obfuscation the app
is simply used to compute the utility
laws we do not
touch i mean we do not train apps model
or
do anything with it it's just used to
compute the utility laws
so that we ensure that the office
creator can keep app essential
information
um the benefits of these approaches
like you have sort of app compatibility
in a sense that
whatever obfuscation mechanism you are
going to come up with
will work with the app without changing
anything in the app
all we need is access to the model um
and as long as we have that um we
we we ensure that the obfuscation
mechanism is work
will work with the app without changing
anything uh
we have verifiable obfuscation um
it's in a this is not a strictly
theoretical sense verifiability but
it's more like one practical side where
since we use this attacker model to
ensure that
the private information is hidden
eventually when the
iterative optimization is reached it
reaches the equilibrium
we know that the attacker is not going
to able to identify any private
information
and not only this article but any
class of these attackers will have the
same property
and we show that in the experiments that
whatever obfuscation we can when we come
up with do
uh does protect against uh class of
adversities
third we can um have privacy trade-off
as i mentioned that sometimes the
private information and use
utility information are very tightly
coupled so it could be
impossible to achieve both in that case
you can use this parameter to
tune whether you want more privacy or
you want more utility
and doing so you can allow
the obfuscation mechanism to basically
learn that way
so it allows the users to to
basically give importance to one or the
other
finally if the scheme itself is data
independent
so like in case of blurring um typically
used for images
um but in this case you don't have like
data
specific or transformation
as long as you have enough information
and terms of training data
you can generate such a notification
mechanism
and in the evaluation section i'll
describe how do we evaluate this on
images as well as sensor data
uh any questions before i move further
yeah um i got a question um
really wondering how um sort of you
verify the obligation
um i'm thinking uh specifically about
i mean i guess a lot of things i mean
one thing would be really nice if you've
actually shown us
some examples of obfuscated uh you know
driver
driver images to see what the model
comes up with but
um you know adversarial examples right
so so famously uh
classifiers also also the work of
goodfellow um
you know classifiers get confused by
just judiciously
manipulating a few pixels uh changes
that are you know virtually undetectable
to humans
can actually turn a you know a
classification of a cat in the
classification of fire truck or ostrich
i mean you know
shocking shocking failures so how do you
know that your attacker
wouldn't you know the uh the obfuscator
just wouldn't learn
adversarial tricks to fool the attacker
and thus
you know you okay your attacker is
stymied your
your obfuscation is you know verified
but but any human
actually looking at the images would you
know very readily be able to tell
um what the original you know all the
the protected information would extract
that very easily
so great question i do have example
images
and i wanted to show you later on but
why don't we directly jump to that
um here
um so this is a slightly different data
set
there is a data set called kth which is
the data set of people performing
different activities
and the goal here was like
to preserve the activity there are like
about six different activities that
people are performing
and i don't remember the exact numbers
but uh roughly the same amount of people
in the data center so the goal was to
ensure that
you cannot identify a person but you can
identify the activity
so on the left you see origin images and
it's not great because the images are
very tiny and so i had to like
make them larger too so that it's easy
to see in the presentation
and on the right you see obfuscated
images so from
humans perspective that's totally
you garbage not know anything that's
happening here so
and i i don't want to claim anything
because we haven't
actually done any evaluation using
humans and asking them hey can you
identify certain things in this
uh just by looking at the images we
thought that this
makes sense um
the the main point here is that we want
the app to work and again when i say app
i mean the model
that's being used to perform activity
recognition to work on the obfuscated
data
without changing the model so in this
case the model
was trained on original images that were
on the left
but it also worked on the obfuscated
images without retraining
that's on the right and that's because
you have that
feedback in the learning obfuscation
mechanism
so the highlighted images i am showing
you are
of the same activity performed by two
different people
and on the right you see sort of similar
looking
blurb uh so it as long as you have the
same activity
it does have the similar
uh information it looks like that at
least on the way
when you when you inspect visually uh
we did test it by generating synthetic
data to verify that
it is indeed the case where we could
preserve features so if you have if you
just so what we did is we
artificially created uh just two
gaussian
and um have no correlation between two
variables one
we assigned as a private one we are send
as a public and then if you run the
obfuscation mechanism that
we just i just described it will simply
randomize the private variable and it
will keep the public variable
so it does preserve that information in
case of images it's hard to
visualize but that's what's happening
under the hood
on the other hand the second row that i
am showing you
is the same person performing different
activities
and on the right you see corresponding
obfuscation where you see very different
images
uh which shows that the
the since it the activities are
different you have different sorts of
features in that output so
this is just to answer how do we know
that
the office creator is not doing some
sort of adversarial tricks
um and actually obfuscating the data
so this is one way to answer that the
second
way to answer the question is
we use this iterative optimization so
so when we when people talk about
adversarial
sorry adversarial examples they do not
necessarily
always talk about retraining the model
on adversarial examples in fact there
are papers that shows that if you do
add advisory example in the training set
the net the model become robust to those
adversarial examples so in our case
when we say attacker we are actually
um giving the attacker all the
obfuscated data
along with the true labels so we give
them whatever you see on the right
along with the labels of identity and
say that
now go and learn to identify people in
these images
and then we that's how we basically
measure privacy
that's how when we say when i say quan
some sort of
verifiability it it's in that sense
uh again i'm not claiming that i have
theoretical guarantees
but in practice when we ran bunch of
different
networks not just the one that's used
for training the obfuscation uh we
show that it is indeed the case that the
network fails to learn in fact
in our uh case we use neural network
as an attacker to train the obfuscation
model
but we when we were verifying the
attacks
ah sorry when we were verifying the
obfuscation mechanism we not only use
neural network we also use
different bunch of models like svm or
random forest and so on
and all of them were trained on these
obfuscated images along with the labels
and were
uh asked to attack the mechanism
okay but you're talking i think maybe
the most striking thing is you're
telling me that an app
like sort of an off-the-shelf app that
was not expecting obfuscation
nonetheless your obfuscator found that
that pattern of
corruption actually conveyed information
that the app was able to use to preserve
its its uh its functionality yes
yeah it's surprising i know i mean again
it's it's not that it we haven't like
extensively tried with a lot of
different cases we tried with bunch of
data sets
and we simulated through
um generating the classifier sorry train
the classifier on those data set and we
show that it works we tried with
a couple of apps but yeah i mean so
again i don't want to claim that it
works in all the cases
but especially things like activity
recognitions or
object recognition it seems to work in
in in these scenarios
so two quick questions related to that
um
are you only able to protect the
information you're enumerating as
private
and the other aspect of is is if you
have a malicious app that you're using
can the app
sneak information through because it's
in your training loop
so again great question so first to
answer the first question yes we are
only protecting the
uh private information that we are
enumerating
uh we do not basically protect anything
that's not
being used during the training and the
second is
yes um it is possible in theory that the
app can
access information during the training
side
um but let's hold on to that question
until i show the experiments because
that will make it i mean
it will be easier to answer that
question there
um any other questions
okay
so yeah i mean we i think we were here
um actually i did have one one question
i think mike asked this originally uh
which was
uh did you try just generating stick
figures
as as some as something that would
remove
personalized or identifying data but
still convey
um the you know what was going on
just reduce everything to a stick figure
um that no we didn't try that
but i know a couple of folks
who did uh work on this
which in which they claim that the gate
of a human can reveal information so the
way you walk
or the way you you move your hands and
stuff
uh also reveal information so they
they've showed that
um just by looking at the stick figure
you can identify a person so
um yeah that that's why we didn't go to
that group
yeah the military the military
discovered that um
for identifying terrorist targets in
foreign countries
but they could identify they could
identify people
um from the the drone footage
uh based upon their gate yeah
yeah i didn't know about that but yeah i
mean
i'm not surprised because and and that
is why we have this
idea of adversarial learning where we
say that
it's very hard to come up with a one fix
approach where
okay blur this or hide this or remove
this information
in the data when you want a general
mechanism so the way we go by is that
okay if we have enough training data set
throw in the training data
specify what is private what is not
private and let the network
figure out what features to to preserve
and what features to hide
and if you think about it let's say
so so for example you have this auto
encoder right which
which takes the image and then basically
maps the information in the image from
the image dimension
to to a very small vector where you have
this middle code layer
and then it basically use that
information
to again uh construct the image
so all you need is that everything that
you need to construct the image is
actually
basically encoded in that factor and if
you visualize that vector it will look
garbage
to you but somehow the network can do
that
and that's that's the basic principle
behind doing all these things and that's
probably answer your question right how
does the app work
with this random looking data because
what
the office creator is doing underlying
the hood is that under the hood is that
you make sure that whatever that
features that are important for the
app or model they are preserved in that
that representation you have and once
you have this all you are doing is just
projecting back to the image domain it
doesn't need to necessarily have the
image
look in a sense it doesn't need to be
human understandable
so that's one of the limitation of our
work so if you want
an obfuscation mechanism that generates
realistic images or realistic data
it doesn't work with this i mean and we
we actually try to do that with this
approach where we say that
let's make sure that both looks similar
because then you can generate realistic
images and realistic data point
but but it was very hard to train such
thing and
preserve the privacy of the data
okay so um basically
the olympus works in two phases you have
an offline phase
where you need three things you need
training data
along with the privacy and utility
labels
you need app and the model of the app
and then you do the iterative
optimization where
you learn the obfuscator oh sorry you
train the obfuscator
by minimizing privacy and utility loss
for privacy loss you send the obfuscated
data to the attacker
and get the loss from the attacker for
utility you send the data to the
apps model and get the utility from the
apps model and
the goal is to minimize this
in the next iteration you train the
attacker where you
maximize the privacy loss so you have
the obfuscated data
you have the true privacy labels and you
try to
find the private information in the data
and whatever loss you get you want to
maximize that loss
so you do this hydrated optimization and
ultimately
you read you stop when the attacker can
no longer identify
private information in the data and in
our case
concretely it basically stops when the
classification is close to random
guessing
and once you have the attacker you you
deploy it
and in the online phase you put it
between sensor and the app
and once you get the data you just apply
the obfuscation
and you feed the obfuscated data to the
app
so let's look at the driver activity
example right
uh we want to identify
activity of a driver but we want to
preserve the privacy of the driver
uh in this case you can have a training
data set where you need bunch of
drivers images and you need to
have privacy labels which are drivers
identity and you also need the utility
labels which are drivers activity
now if you're using an app you can
simply get those labels from the app
since our goal is to make sure that it
works with the app we are not
really looking for true activity levels
all we need is whatever classifier of
the app gives us
and that should be sufficient um
so getting a utility label should be
fairly easy but
privacy labels you need some manual work
or some public data set
um then once we have the training data
we need to basically figure out what are
the losses so
typically in this case for privacy loss
you can use some sort of cross amber
trophy loss
that can be used to predict driver's
identity
and for the utility loss you can do the
same that predicts the activity
or whatever apps model is using is loss
and here is an example of an office
schedule which is
essentially an auto encoder so you get
the unpartnered image
you apply some series of convolution
and then you have this middle layer
which we call it code layer which
contains all the information about the
data
and then you basically up sample it back
to the
original image so
this is what i was referring to earlier
where
everything is essentially boils down to
preserving whatever information you want
to do in code layer and throwing out
everything else
so that when you project it back into
the image domain
you ensure that only app essential
information is preserved
and rest is thrown away um
you can achieve this by essentially
minimizing privacy and utility loss
in this case cross-sectoral loss of
identifying the driver's identity and
the activity
in the attacker is basically
convolutional neural network which takes
the obfuscated image
applies series of convolutions and then
finally applies the softmax to predict
the
probability of each driver and
the goal here is to maximize this
privacy loss in other words you want to
be able to accurately identify the
driver
so with once we have these two networks
you can
basically run the mini max optimization
algorithm
and then once you are uh
once you achieve the equilibrium which
is the attacker can no longer
identify the driver you can use the
office cater
trained here to just obfuscate the
future data points
okay so um for evaluation
we basically evaluated the mechanism on
three fronts
and the first one is utility which
basically
tries to capture how well the olympus is
preserving app essential information
and we capture it through accuracy of
the apps model
the second one is privacy which tells
how well
olympus hides private information and
this is captured through accuracy
of the attacker and finally we
have a uk study where we apply this to a
real world app
and show that indeed the app works so
here are the data sets that we used for
evaluation
uh we have two image data sets and two
motion sensor data set
um all the data sets are
essentially used to get
basically used for activity recognition
um
and you see on the utility classes
column the number of activities
performed
at each data set um and then
for private information we use identity
as the
variable that you want to protect and
you have
on the last column the number of private
classes so number of identities in the
data center
now state farm is highlighted because
that simulates the distracted driving
scenarios that we were talking about it
basically has
bunch of images where there are people
are
driving in a car and they're performing
one of the 10 activities
and there are 10 such people in the data
set so we want to preserve the activity
that's the they are doing and uh
sorry yeah one want to preserve the
activity and
hide the identity and we do the
trainings in a standard fashion we split
the data set into training validation
and test set
we uh train the olympics using training
set
and then use the validation to pick the
best of the skater and then
use the test set to evaluate the
learned obfuscated off scatter
so here is the graph that shows you how
the app and attacker works as we
train the model so on
x-axis you see the number of epochs the
number of training iterations
and on the y-axis you see accuracy um
this is for the kth data set which has
about six
users and six uh activities
the green horizontal bar tells you the
accuracy of random guessing
when you are guessing the identity of a
person um
the blue one tells you the accuracy of
the app
uh on the office scatter data and the
red one tells you the accuracy of the
attacker on the official scripted data
so what's happening here as we start
the typically the office skater and this
brings back to the question where
during the training are we revealing
information to the app
or any malicious adversaries um so
so one answer to that is
if you have a set of training data set
that's available and that's public
you can use that and that's the best
option to do in that case you don't have
to worry about leaking information
during the training however
our hypothesis and again this is not
theoretically sound
but we do not uh the way it structure we
don't reveal too much information
to the attacker during the training as
well and
this is what this graph shows so as we
start
initially the the obfuscator is just
randomly initialized so whatever output
it has is typically random
and as the uh
training progresses the utility loss
will
force the office creator to keep app
essential information and that's where
you see
as you move along the training path you
see the increasing
apps accuracy like the accuracy of apps
start keeps increasing
on the other hand the accuracy of the
attacker stays
close to random because the
privacy loss will ensure that you're not
adding or leaking any information in the
output
um so
if there is a leak in the information
you would see high accuracy of the
attacker
along the training but typically it
stays close to random so
we are not leaking too much information
and this is what we have seen in
almost all the data sets and all the
training iterations that we did
so that that's that's the answer of the
question
and this is basically the graph that
shows uh for all four data sets the
accuracy of the apps classifier on
original and the part of data
so the blue bar shows you the accuracy
of the
on the original data and the green one
shows you accuracy on the obfuscated
data
x axis is the data sets you see the
number of classes
in this and y axis is the accuracy
so for the heart and opportunity which
are sensor dataset
we achieve very similar results
on perturbed and unput up data um there
is a slight drop in the accuracy
on the image classification and uh
typically
in cases like this it's it's hard
because there is a very tight
correlation between the identity
and activities such as whether the
person is looking in front or not
so due to this we do see a slight drop
in the accuracy
and that's the price we need to pay to
protect the
privacy
now this slide shows you uh
how accurately we preserve the privacy
of
uh in in the obfuscated data
so again we have these four data sets on
the second column we see
number of privacy classes these are
number of people in the data set
and we use a separate neural network
that's trained from scratch
on labeled office data data and then we
run
the uh we evaluate that attacker on
held out test set so first uh
the column shows you uh accuracy on
unprotop data so if we train an attacker
on
unpart of data this is what we get like
we
almost every time able to accurately
find the person in the data which is not
surprising
however when we apply the obfuscation
the accuracy drops significantly
and the last column shows you the
accuracy of random
guessing so as we see
in the table the numbers are very close
so
with the office skater the
attacker is not able to guess anything
more than random guessing
and as i mentioned uh we also did
experiments
not only using the neural network but we
also use bunch of other
models like random forest or logistic
regressions and so on
and those give similar results
uh if you are interested you can look at
the paper
i can share the link later on in the
chat
and finally we did the case study on
an app uh it's a handwriting recognition
app
that was available on play store uh
which was using tensorflow model
so we downloaded the app and the
goal here is that using the handwriting
style you can identify a person uh
so the so so the privacy problem that we
post here is that we want to obfuscate
a handwritten digit so that you can
protect
the identity of the person but you can
still get the
maintain the accuracy of digit
recognition
uh so we have these privacy unity goals
set
we collected bunch of training data for
this case study
we picked two users we asked them to
draw images and we collected 300 images
of their handwriting for user we label
them manually
and then we deploy uh
basically we perform this experiment on
nexus 9 tablet
so we did instrument the uh nexus time
so that
as soon as the um the user draws
something on the
screen we capture the information before
it reaches the app
so you can hook different sorts of apis
to do that
and for this i think we use xposed
framework which is publicly available
it's open source
uh you can instrument the android os to
hook any of the
android apis and that will allow you to
access the data before it
gets to the app um
so we use the model uh of the app
electron transfer model to train the
obfuscator
using the training data and then put up
the images
and then we use the perturbed images to
evaluate how well
it works with the app and we also
separately trained an attacker to
attack these obfuscated images so
the results are shown in this graph on
x-axis you have
the accuracy of both app and the
attacker
again blue bars are unput up images
green ones are the obfuscated
perturbed images and the y-axis is
accuracy so
in case of the app we achieve similar
performance
and there is a very slight drop
and but most of the time we were the app
was able to identify the
digit correctly even in the obfuscated
data and remember
this app is it's downloaded from the
play store we do not change anything on
that
side the attacker
on the other hand was able to identify
the identity with high accuracy
on the original images that shows that
it is indeed possible to
identify user by their handwriting
but after the obfuscation the
performance of the attacker was close to
random guessing
uh we also measure the time because
that's the another added
cost you pay because you are now
obfuscating the data
but on nexus 9 it was the median time
sorry the mean time to confiscate the
image was about eight milliseconds
so it wasn't too bad to
run the obfuscator on the device itself
okay so to summarize uh
we basically propose a utility aware
obfuscation mechanism that uses minimax
optimization approach
uh the idea is to have a competing
networks that
uh help each other so that you can
learn the notification mechanism as well
as verify
that it's really uh working and
on a bunch of the benchmark there's our
data sets we show that
olympus hides private information
without significantly
affecting the app's accuracy and we also
show
uh by instrumenting android os that
it you can actually use that in practice
by
intercepting the data office getting the
data and it
does work with the app without changing
anything on the website
so yeah that's it um thank you so much
um if you have any questions yeah feel
free to ask
thanks nizark um yeah i think there's a
couple questions
in the chat but they might have been
answered does anybody want to
ask any questions now
yeah um and there's a marvelous proof of
concept demonstration but
um of course you're really working
proving it out with very very sort of
small tasks so far uh especially with
the the real app
um distinguishing being you know between
two people
um what happens as you try to push this
uh with sort of larger more sort of real
world data sets
so um i i think larger data sets would
help certainly because the more
data you have it's you are feeding the
office cutter more information
um the tricky part is
not about the large data sets the tricky
part is
what happens if we have other variants
like
things like identity and
activities seems to be working fine but
we haven't really tested on
other attributes such as like
simultaneously there is another
uh group of people who did apply similar
work uh
who did apply similar techniques and
they showed that it also works for
things like race and gender
but more complex things like for example
what if you want to hide
i don't know a number plate license
plate
in in a google street view
can you use this type of techniques or
what if something that's very
tightly coupled with the the information
that you really want
uh so that's something that is
unexplored um
and the other thing is getting the
label data is slightly harder for these
tasks so
especially with the private information
yeah i was just thinking i mean larger
basis but
these would in turn you know require
larger models in the app
and so you know the digit recognition
you know a very small model will do and
maybe that somehow
you know sort of really simplifies the
problem relative to
a task that's um you know detecting um
whether you know lesions skin lesions or
cancerous or not you know something one
of these medical apps
uh so it yeah i i understand uh on to be
honest with you we haven't tried that
but we did try activity recognition
which is not as simple as digit
recognition
um i
we'd also tried uh object recognition so
we have these c fart and
popular vision data sets which has
different sorts of objects in it
we experimented with those objects and
we were able to identify the objects but
things like skin lesion and all
uh we haven't tried it um
my hypothesis it should be possible as
long as
your private information is not tightly
coupled with the things that you want
for example the fact that you have a
classifier that is able to identify
uh skill lesson from the raw data or
from the original image
means that it is possible to identify
information from the data
uh it is possible to classify them so
adding an office question
so okay let me rephrase that imagine a
scenario where you don't have any
private information right so the
attacker will
basically doesn't need to do anything in
that case
what office cutter is doing is just
learning an identity function
so it's just going to output the same
image and then in that case the app
works perfectly fine
and when i say perfectly fine i mean
whatever accuracy the app classifier has
will be preserved in the case when you
have a private information that's where
the office creator is forced to
remove some information so that really
depends on
what is your private information it's
not so much on
what classifier or what app essential
information is it's it's so much about
the correlation between the private and
public information as well as what are
the private information
not sure if that makes sense or did i
answer your question no that's that's
helpful
thanks
anyone else
yeah i guess i'll follow up briefly um
if this
comes to fruition uh what is the
whose privacy are you protecting from
whom with this is this something where i
cannot trust the app
um but i have to trust your obfuscator
i'm trying to figure out kind of like
where in the chain i still have to trust
someone here
i see so yes so the office getter
um so we have one separate paper where
we try to establish a privacy framework
for mobile os
which is sort of a plug-in driven
framework so imagine you have these
browsers right and
you have a bunch of plugins for example
ad blocker
i use that and i trust the ad blocker um
and i don't really know the internal
letters but typically it's open source
so
people as a community have trusted that
thing and
they can look into it and figure out
what's
happening so so that same principle that
we used
to build a privacy framework that's plug
and driven and the idea in that paper
was
we we have these privacy plugins
where privacy experts can write those
plugins
and typically they are open source and
you have this platform and
you can basically
put the plugins in between the source
like the sensor data and the apps so
that
you can trust the operating system and
the plugins and
when i say trust plugins i mean uh they
are open source so it's easy to trust
them
and so so really what you're doing is
you're just trusting the
operating system and we also limit the
damage the plugin does uh in that
framework so that
even if a plug-in is malicious it's
going to only
uh affect the data that you are sharing
the plugin with
it's not going to affect everything else
in the system uh
so to to to the short answer is
uh yes you do have to trust someone and
the the idea here is that
we build these office creators make them
open source
so that people can write it audited and
then
deploy them within the operating system
so that once you trust the operating
system
you're fine you don't have to trust
anything else outside the os
thank you yeah very interesting
presentation
thanks so i think there's a question
from mike in the chat um what
will you do to convince those who would
purchase your technology
that the gan filter won't degrade their
detection
um well
i would just run the gan filter on the
app and show that it is indeed working
i guess that's the only thing you can do
um
but so while i was working on this there
is another
limitation of this is this needs to be
shared like the app model needs to be
shared
at least to run these uh
it is to be used during the training
training and
collect the utility labels and that
might be one of the bottleneck because
um the companies in general may not be
willing to share that
and the argument we um
the only solution that i can think of is
then the companies
themselves should provide these
obfuscator and they should train it
and in some sense it's beneficial
because
now not only your app is going to work
with this office question
but you also can
give more stronger claims on privacy and
say that hey we do collect this
information from you
but we are not really actually leaking
any sensitive information because we are
not even receiving those sensitive
information
um yeah
that's the best answer i could come up
with
a question from david
on the adversary model what does the
honest but curious adversary model mean
so honest but curious model means
the attacker is going to do whatever it
claims to do but it can
use its power to identify
whatever information it can from the
data that you
share it with so it's not going to for
example collude with someone
other party so typically in the
realistic setting the
you you have different sorts of
assumptions so for example what if the
attacker
collides with the app and then get the
information
well in that case you can't do anything
with this
particular solution uh so if when we say
honest but curious we mean
the attacker is not going the author is
going to follow the protocol
meaning it's not going to do collusion
it's not going to get any external
information
uh it's going to do whatever it's stated
but
it can whatever data it has which is
known it can do whatever in its power to
exploit that data
yeah that's what it means and the
attacker is not a passive observer it's
actually an active adversary meaning uh
so in the in the realm of things we do
assume the office
gator is sitting within the os and the
os is trusted
and the apps are outside os boundaries
so once the data leaves the
os boundaries which is after the
obfuscation
the attacker can access the data and do
whatever it can
with the data so it's not really passive
it's just it actively
uh accessing the information um and it
can
it can train itself with enough labels
to
to simulate the to try to learn their
private information and that's what we
actually do during the evaluation we
give
bunch of obfuscated data along with the
privacy labels and
ask the attacker hey go and try to learn
and break the obfuscation
got it yep sweet so i think those were
all the questions does anyone have
anything else
if not thank you for your time sorry
this was a great talk
great talks tonight everyone thank you
great so uh our last uh part of the
conference
are lightning talks so if anyone has
any want to talk about any data science
topic for like five to ten minutes um in
any format
uh now's the time i think uh mark you
had
you had a talk to share yes let me share
my screen can you hear me
yes okay
let's
share are you seeing
jupiter lab shortcut problem on windows
yeah i see it
okay so i i use anaconda
as as my uh
distribution change change management
for
uh the open source products that i use
and i installed jupyter lab but when i
went to run it
uh i got stuck in a loop
and so it would it would start up and
then
i'd see the screen but the screen really
wouldn't
allow me to get control and
in the background uh the uh the kernel
was in a loop and it wasn't it wasn't uh
uh tried it wasn't able to see or write
to a particular directory and
the first thing that i did was okay let
me just
start up anaconda and then in anaconda
i can run this command
let's see i can run
this command and this is in windows
and and that would do it but i really
wasn't satisfied with
not using the shortcut because the
shortcut is is
it's handy just double click on it and
it's it's done
so i looked around and
the shortcut itself was the problem
and what you'll see here this is all one
string that's in the shortcut
um so so what you're seeing on many
lines is actually on one line
and as it turns out i didn't realize
this that the there's a 168 character
limit
on shortcuts
and it crosses lots of windows boundary
lots of windows versions
but there is that hard limit
second thing that you'll you should
notice is that
all of the all of these
include or all of these paths
down into um see users public documents
and
anaconda 3 to
to describe what's what's to be done
so what i did
was create a an environment variable so
if i right click on uh computer
properties
and then uh go to this advanced system
settings
and then in advanced system settings the
dialog
box has environment variables and then i
created a new environment variable
called anaconda3 which
is that string then i can go back
and substitute all of those instances of
that
that path name with percent anaconda 3
percent
which automatically does the
substitution with the with the set
variables
and it starts up
it starts up just just fine now so
that was that was a problem and i didn't
realize that that was a
a problem but it's it seems like the
most elegant solution because now i've
got a shortcut back
any questions did you ever
start jupiter lab from a different
continent
environment so i guess i'm wondering how
you would handle
different virtual environments
um i really only have one
i really only have one anaconda
environment
and within anaconda you can
and and you can't specify okay the
version
uh the version i want to start up of
julia
or python or whatnot um is
a particular a particular version that
is under the umbrella of anaconda
but i i only have one anaconda
environment
right i only have one anaconda install
too i meant
like like multiple python virtual
environments under that
i often run different versions of
jupiter lab
inside a different anaconda environment
um you know and i just from a windows
command line i just do con to activate
and the environment that i want and then
i launched jupiter lab from that
environment right and and that would go
back to if
if i were if i
if i had that problem then i would
probably fall back to
um opening up the anaconda prompt and
then
with a command line with a command line
directive
at um within the anaconda
prompt environment uh specify what i
needed to
in terms of version or starting location
etc
yeah yeah okay
okay thank you as promised
it was it was a technical it was a
technical talk this month
thanks mark anyone else lightning talk
all right cool um yeah if nothing
else uh thanks everyone for joining um
the may pi data conference and um
our next meetup will be july 7th so
i'll see everyone there